hey leute was glaub herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video
wir haben letztens angekündigt wie
machten einen zuschauer kräften wir sind
jetzt schon in bielefeld und gleich sind
wir da ich bin voll nervig findet der
kameras herausgefunden
würd mal sagen ich mach' paar aufnahmen
oder so wir sehen uns dann gleich viel
spaß
was meint ihr wie viele kommen was dazu
ja leute habe ich noch eine sonnenbrille
aufgesetzt und ich würde sagen wir
nähern uns immer mehr
ich bin sowieso ich habe so ein gefühl
wie vor meiner sport letzten mündlichen
prüfung bei sport ohne witz alles
zittert die anspannung kommt weiter nach
oben alle gucken mich dumm an weil ich
so eine fette kamera hab so was ich noch
sagen wollte ich habe noch mit meiner
freundin geschrieben
seit freundin also die macht auf youtube
und der also ein zuschauer treffen
gemacht und sie muss er 2000 euro strafe
zahlen weil es ja nicht angemeldet war
und das ist auch nicht angemeldet das
heißt wenn wir jetzt gleich ein wir sind
richtig wenn wir jetzt gleich da sind
und zu viele da sind dann gehen wir
einfach wieder weg ich glaub ich mache
muss ich zu viel geld bezahlen das will
ich auch nicht
live
leider gibt darüber leistung
oder er pendelt
meine frau
alex
wir sind jetzt wieder im auto auf dem
weg zurück so wir sind halt erwarte ich
einmal abgehauen dann was komplett
heftig dass er wirklich so eine krasse
erfahrung für mich so die man zusammen
weil du warst ja wirklich du eigentlich
auch nicht alleine gestellt und konnte
nichts machen aber auch keiner der
gesagt hat schilder oder so hat doch
ziehen hier die beiden erstmal kurz
davor und danke an euch ja manchmal
gesagt dass das wirklich so die höheren
afghani zurück das vielleicht heftig wir
sind jetzt auf dem weg nach hause das
fenster hielt karst kann man einfach so
wegschieben regnet einfach machen
einfach so wer das jahr fixiert die
technik begeistern gerade auf jeden fall
was mit dem video keine ahnung
vielleicht mache ich das irgendwann
nochmal so aber es ist auf jeden fall so
eine sache damit hat man schon so ein
bisschen respekt jetzt vor weil man
wirklich weiß was da abging und so
vielen dank an alle die da waren ich
habe jetzt ziemlich viel coole sachen
bekommen guck mir gleich erstmal an das
was mit dem video wird mich selbst wenn
ihr doch nach oben schaut doch mal bei
ihnen vorbei alles in der video
beschreibung verlinkt
alles klar
wir sehen uns an kommende woche wieder
kommt das 300.000 akustische wenn ihr
wenn ihr aktiv sei knapp 4000 abos das
schafft man wohl